mr argo a very good morning to you let
me put first of all to you if i may what
we heard from the then culture secretary
on the very day that an event was taking
place uh about an hour later on the 20th
of may 2020 the very height of lockdown
this is what the culture secretary was
saying
those who cannot work from home should
now speak to their employer about going
back to work
you can spend time outdoors and exercise
as often as you like and you can meet
one person outside your household in an
outdoor public place provided that you
stay two meters apart
so just to clarify straight off the bat
mr
argher good morning how does that tally
with what happened
at downing street less than an hour
later
well okay um good morning we've seen and
heard obviously in recent days the
allegations about what happened it's
absolutely right that sue gray a very
senior and very well respected civil
servant is independently looking into
these i wasn't at any
parties i don't know um about these
allegations so it's right they're
investigated properly because as you
alluded to in your introduction there i
can understand we've lost in this
country 150 230 i think is the latest
figure of our fellow citizens who've
died from this disease so i can
understand
that with these allegations people will
be upset and angry which is why it's
right that the prime minister asked for
that independent investigation to be
completed at pace to get to the facts
behind these allegations would you have
accepted the invitation
um kay i spent my may last year
talking to you on various occasions and
various other
media outlets but pretty much glued to
my
zoom screen and making sure that i knew
what the regulations were not least
because i was a health minister who
helped draw them up
given that would you have accepted the
invitation
i wasn't uh okay i wasn't invited to any
parties and i'm not going to get into
any hypotheticals i was clear about what
the well hey i was clear about what the
rules were at the time and it's right
that sue gray is looking into this
matter independently
uh the police said at the at the time
this is a tweet from the police on the
20th of may from the met police they say
um have you been enjoying the hottest
day of the year so far it's important
that we all continue to stay alert you
can relax have a picnic exercise or play
sport as long as you are on your own
with people you live with just you and
one other person does it sound as though
that is what was happening in the garden
of downing street the very same day
sorry i i don't know um what did or
didn't happen all i've seen of the
report the email that was reported
yesterday and various sources quoted by
various media and journalistic outlets
that's why it's right that this is
looked into independently by sue gray
and therefore be wrong for me to comment
while she's doing that and equally while
we've heard um i think overnight that
the metropolitan police have said
they're in communication with the
cabinet office so given those
circumstances i don't think it would be
appropriate for me to comment on what
she may or may not conclude but let her
get on with her job with that clear
field without any um
comment from ministers or others and let
her reach the conclusion she reaches
hopefully swiftly we've all seen the
email invitation it says join us uh it's
from martin reynolds martin reynolds
would only write join us if it was from
the prime minister wouldn't he
well i'm not sure um that's as i say i i
have seen the email i don't know the
context of that email and i think that
you're um you're making a leap there in
assuming and making an assumption about
the prime minister i'm not going to be
drawn on that i think that again as i
say and i know it will be frustrating
for you but i think i have to repeat it
because it's the it's the right thing to
do is that that's up to ms gray to look
into and while her investigation is
going on i'm not going to make comments
that would pre-judge or get in the way
of that okay so the police were tweeting
at the time saying uh you can meet but
just with one other person police in
derbyshire
were actually putting up drones at the
very same time this is what they were
doing they were looking to see whether
people were walking on their own in the
peak district with or with other people
whether they were walking their dog
whether they were too close uh and
whether they were from the same
household were the police in derbyshire
going too far that day
well i think and i this is where i will
try and rely on my memory of that time
if i recall that the derbyshire police
subsequently
suggested it did say that um
that maybe they had
gone too far on that particular occasion
but what the police were seeking to i
spoke to my own chief constable in
leicestershire a lot at that time and
his focus with his officers was to
inform and educate as the first step so
to intervene and talk to people if he if
their officers thought that um that the
rules were not being followed and only
as a last resort to take enforcement
action that way bringing the public with
him and his officers and i do remember
the conversations i had with him at that
time back in i think may late may of
2020. you may remember a news conference
that the prime minister gave on the 25th
of may 2020 in response to a question
about big groups gathering in parks
boris johnson said the only reason we
have been able to make as much progress
as we have is because this country has
observed the social distancing rules so
feel free to speak to people yourself if
you feel they are not obeying the rules
but the police will step in if necessary
and encourage people to obey the law
do you had seen 40 people gathering in
the garden of downing street would you
have stepped in
well you're you're citing a hypothetical
there okay i wasn't in downing street
i don't think i went to downing street
at all during that period of the
pandemic i spent most of it sitting as i
say glued to a zoom or team's screen
but i think we all at that time we
remember what it was like
and i think we all and i think you
probably asked me at the time um would i
if i for example had people next door or
in the street having a party or breaking
the rules what would we do and what
would i say i made clear that i might
have
a quiet word but i'm not going to
extrapolate from that or be drawn on the
allegations at the moment they're being
investigated by sue gray so i'm not
going to i'm afraid uh get into
hypotheticals about that i think it's
important she has the field clear to do
her job to investigate that to talk to
who she needs to to get that information
and reach her conclusions about the
facts of what did or didn't happen
if 40 people were gathered in the garden
of dining street on the 20th of may 2020
was that against the rules
well i'm going to let sue gray get on
with her job in looking into what
actually happened you're asking me i'm a
hypothetical that i appreciate we've
seen the reports recently i'm sorry
health ministry i'm sorry it's not
hypothetical
on the 20th of may 2020 was that against
the rules as we understood them given
the facts that i've just given to you at
the time
well i can set out to you what the rules
were and you can form your own
conclusions and your viewers will but
i'm not going to prejudge what sue wolf
sue grey will find happened on that
occasion so you're in a sense completing
two things the rules you're right you
played i think oliver dowden there who
was coach secret time at the beginning
setting out what the rules were but what
actually happened or didn't happen in
downing street is a matter for ms gray
and she will come up with her
conclusions having interviewed the
relevant people having looked at the
evidence and that she will then conclude
a what did or didn't happen and then b
whether
anything that did happen was consistent
with the rules but the rules are as you
set out i think at the outset of this
piece as oliver dowden set out in that
press conference
let's fast forward then to the end of
last year the prime minister
has certainly said i've not got any mud
or blood on my hands at the moment there
might have been parties going on in
downing street i wasn't aware of them
and this is what he said in
the house of commons at the time
i apologize for
uh for the impression that uh has been
given uh that staff and danny street
take this less than seriously uh i'm i'm
i'm sickened myself and furious about
that
want to say anything about that
well i think the prime minister was was
right to apologize um for that as i said
i've i've been a minister in the
department of health throughout this
pandemic i've spoken to you a lot and on
each occasion um every day i've followed
very closely the number of people in
hospital the number of people who've
sadly and tragically died from this
disease so i can entirely understand as
i said people's anger and frustration
and upset and hurt at these allegations
and suggestions and that's why the prime
minister was right um to come to the
house and to apologize for that i think
he did absolutely the right thing in
doing that and in setting up this
investigation
he says he was sickened by parties going
on at dining street it looks as though
he was at least two at least two of them
well again you are
citing something based on some reports
some sources but we don't know the facts
and that's what sue gray is going to be
looking at i i know sue great she is an
extremely experienced
integrity she will follow the facts
she will follow the facts and she will
report on what she finds and i think
it's important we let her do that job
quite rightly you and others would quite
rightly be the first to say if i started
prejudging what she was going to say or
seeking to influence it that that was
inappropriate it would be that's why
it's important i say i will wait to see
what she says and if she finds any
evidence of wrongdoing or rules broken
it's important that appropriate
disciplinary action follows that
we've seen the photographs we've seen
the documentary evidence we've seen what
the met have said we've seen what the
prime minister has said we've seen what
the culture secretary has said rather
than the prime minister being sickened
shouldn't it be the public that is
sickened
well i've already said i can entirely
understand why these allegations these
suggestions these reports
will cause
great upset and anger with people that's
why it's right that the prime minister
because of the time and everyone making
huge sacrifices sadly many lives lost
that's why it's right that the prime
minister said he wants to get to the
bottom of this he's commissioned that
independent investigation but i'm not
going to
give a commentary on what ms gray may or
may not conclude nor indeed given the
news overnight that they met are in
communication with the cabinet office
what they may or may not conclude so i
think it's important they're both
allowed to have those conversations in
mrs gray's case to conclude that
investigation and make the findings
known
you're looking my viewers in the eye
this morning um
health minister nobody would have wanted
your job this morning
how can you defend this prime minister
what i'm saying is very clear i've made
clear as someone who's been a health
minister and as you know throughout this
pandemic um i can understand the
the hurt that these reports these
allegations um well of course
particularly for those who've lost
loved ones yesterday i did what i
sometimes do which is walk along the
memorial wall on the south bank so i
know i can entirely understand the
pain people have experienced through
this pandemic and the pain people have
experienced through the restrictions
they had to endure which is why i think
it's absolutely right the prime minister
may the same he did and commissioned an
independent investigation into it and i
look forward to seeing the results of
that investigation that's absolutely the
right thing to do
and i hope that ms gray will report as
swiftly as she can i haven't given you
allegations minister i've given you
facts this morning
you have uh cited the email you've cited
um reports and journalistic sources uh
suggesting certain things it's important
that ms gray as an independent figure
an independent civil servant looks into
this and is able to investigate it fully
and has the feel clear for her to do
that likewise
that the police who said they've been in
communication with the cabinet office
again are able to have those
conversations it wouldn't be appropriate
in that context for me to comment on
those ongoing conversations or her
ongoing investigation we've got to give
her um the space to conclude that
investigation to speak to whoever she
needs to and to reach her conclusions
without fear or favor
when will we hear from her
well if i recall i think the prime
minister said he wanted her to conclude
this investigation as swiftly as
possible because people wanted to know
the answers but that is a matter for her
because i think setting an arbitrary
timeline um would risk
limiting her being able to go where she
wants to go and pursue whichever lines
of inquiry but i know he was clear he
wanted this to be a swift investigation
a swift report to get to the bottom of
of the allegations which i know is what
the public would want to
and do you feel it's now right that the
police are involved
well i've seen saw the reply you saw the
report overnight saying that they were
in communication with the cabinet office
um i shouldn't comment further that's a
matter for the police um but they as
ever throughout this they will make
operational decisions and and that is a
matter for them to decide um what to
pursue what conversations to have but i
do know that they've said they have had
conversations or in conversation with
the cabinet office as i said minister
few would envy your position this
morning um having to defend uh what is
across all of the newspapers and most of
the broadcast media we appreciate you
taking the time to join us thank you